what are we
what do we stand for if season three of
the Mandalorian has you feeling baby
Yoda fever all over again here are five
more shows like this that are totally
worth checking out
Pedro Pascal guiding an orphan through
dangerous terrain may seem like old hat
now but the Mandalorian was the first to
do it and now has yet another fresh
musty season underway there's something
dangerous happening out there and by the
time it becomes big enough for you to
act
it'll be too late
with more Pedro more Star Wars and more
hero and sidekick fun this list will be
your perfect companion starting with our
brand new and somewhat obvious pick The
Last of Us released on HBO and HBO Max
in January this series quickly became a
hit and one of the most talked about
shows in a long time and what matters
here today is that it gives you what the
Mandalorian can which is more Pedro
Pascal I mean it's just so nice being
able to see his face now after just one
certified fresh season The Last of Us is
now widely considered among critics to
be one of the greatest video game
adaptations like ever which is pretty
impressive because we all know how
Gamers can be kidding now while you wait
for the officially greenlit season 2
it'll take you around 10 hours to watch
the first season and then a couple days
to totally process what you just watched
just FYI but in a good way keep going
for family
I'm not family no
your cargo
making the journey as our throwback pick
is the Lone Wolf and Cub franchise which
includes six films and a TV series this
manga story was first published in 1970
and it screams Mandalorian as it's
centered around an assassin father and a
three-year-old son who traveled together
seeking revenge over the years critics
have praised the sword work of the
actors and twists and turns of the story
saying that this franchise has the rare
type of film that succeeds as low brow
visceral entertainment or as high
concept art kind of like my Instagram
you can binge all six movies in just
about eight and a half hours and maybe
you'll pick up a few pointers on how to
entertain a young child the is Duo
imaginable
father and son who could take on an
entire Army known far and wide as Lone
Wolf and Cub bringing some Rebellion to
this list is our audience pick Andor now
with fan favorite Diego Luna leading the
way as Thief turned Rebel Spy Cassian
Andor this series takes us into
previously unseen parts of the Star Wars
Universe much like Mandalorian after a
certified fresh first season Andor holds
the highest Tomato Meter score out of
all the live-action Star Wars shows with
critics calling it an exceptionally
mature and political entry into the
Mythos with the second and final season
probably not coming until 2024 you can
actually watch the 12 episode first
season in about nine hours and then
you're going to want to watch it again
because it's seriously that good they're
so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine not someone like me
would ever get inside their house
climbing out of a sarlacc pit to be our
editor's pick is the book of Boba Fett
now this series takes place at the same
time as and even crosses over with the
Mandalorian it features Tamora Morrison
as Boba Fett and migna Wen it's Fenix
Shan both reprising their roles from
previous Star Wars media and I just
personally love that Trend now while it
hasn't garnered quite the same praise as
Mando and Andor the first season is
still fresh on the Tomato Meter and
critics say that It ultimately earns its
commission with spectacular set pieces
and Morrison's commanding presence no
official word yet on a second season but
in the meantime you can actually watch
the first season in just over five hours
and then you too may be able to survive
a sarlacc pit
I am not a bounty hunter
I've heard otherwise
we finally are certified Fresh Pick is a
another live-action Star Wars series and
my personal favorite Obi-Wan Kenobi and
much like our boy denjarin AKA Mando
Obi-Wan is a bit of a Solo Traveler in
this series and he winds up with some
Precious Cargo of his own as he tries to
look after a young Princess Leia with
Hayden Christensen reprising his role as
Darth Vader and of course you and
McGregor returning as Obi-Wan critics
praise the certified fresh fur season
especially McGregor's Soulful
performance paired with some refreshing
twists so you'll only need about four
and a half hours to get through the
first season which leaves you plenty of
time to keep practicing your Force
Powers May the force be with you leave
us alone when the time comes he must be
trained like you trained his father
okay so hopefully this will take your
next few binge sessions to a galaxy far
far away be sure to let us know what
you're currently streaming in the
comments and check back here for more
recommendations based on the shows you
love right here on Rotten Tomatoes more
like this I'm Naz Perez and I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
thank you